el sábado por la noche en abdurman un
incendio en medio de una ciudad
densamente poblada desprende humo negro
a la mañana siguiente las columnas de
humo siguen suspendidas en el aire y se
oyen disparos
son las secuelas de un ataque aéreo que
según el Ministerio de sanidad mató a
más de 20 personas el ataque fue
duramente condenado por las Naciones
Unidas
el secretario general sigue
profundamente preocupado por el hecho de
que la guerra en curso entre las fuerzas
armadas haya llevado a Sudán al borde de
una guerra civil a gran escala lo que
podría desestabilizar toda la región
el ataque se produjo cuando el conflicto
entre el ejército sudanés y el grupo
paramilitar rival fuerzas de apoyo
rápido entraban en su décimo tercera
semana los paramilitares culparon al
ejército del ataque pero este negó la
acusación los residentes afirman que las
FARC han tomado las casas de la gente
como escudos mientras son atacadas por
los militares el Ministerio de sanidad
dice que más de 3000 personas han muerto
en el conflicto y cada vez hay más
denuncias de violencia sexual según la
organización internacional para las
migraciones 2,9 millones de personas han
sido desplazadas internamente o han oído
a través de las fronteras